i've been debating whether to make this
video but i realize
that after hearing so many stories
that sound so similar me making
a video that could possibly help
one person not go through the same
things is worth
more than feeling
uncomfortable and staying silent because
of that i just want to put out a
disclaimer
well a few disclaimers actually please
watch to the end um
i really don't want people to get the
wrong idea of what i'm trying to say
and i really don't want to scare people
away from coming into
the games industry which i work in and i
love this video is to help with possible
red flags that you might
come across when you're trying to get
into the games industry or you're
working in the games industry or
something like that but that is in no
way supposed to be
victim blaming at the end of the day
these awkward
uncomfortable horrible situations
in the workplace should not happen and i
shouldn't be having
to tell you about these red flags and
people shouldn't be having to come out
with their own
recurrences of what has been happening
to them
this should not be happening um but
until we
talk about it we raise awareness of it
it's possibly not going to stop and i
don't want this to happen in the future
disclaimer number two this is not a all
meant a trash
type of video please don't take it as
that
right now i do work in the games
industry i work with all different types
of
genres genders i can't speak today
what is wrong with me i work with all
genders i work with multiple different
races
and ages and i honestly feel
respected and treated as a human
while being there so i don't want this
video to be about scaring you
away from the games industry no i want
you to realize that
it is not okay if anyone makes you feel
these types of ways
it is not something that is inherent
throughout the whole of the games
industry
so it should not be taken lightly
and you should not think that it's
normal there are many companies i'm sure
within the gaming industry that will
treat you with the respect that you
deserve because you deserve it and
disclaimer number three
i am speaking mainly from a girl's
perspective from a female's viewpoint
because
that is what i identify as and it's all
i've ever known
throughout my life and i would like this
video to kind of be something that
would have helped me back when i started
my career um so i am thinking about
little tiny me in the past right so who
am i
um why am i talking about this topic i
am a game designer i have been working
as an associate game designer
um for almost two years now i did a
traineeship for my first year
um and i was trying to break into the
games industry
uh many years
basically since i was in college i've
noticed that throughout that time
i have grown to be
perhaps a bit wary and distrustful
at first and that's just my disposition
um perhaps it's due to some
things that may or may not be universal
i don't know
i always thought that perhaps it was
just normal to be a little bit
distrusting and to always be on guard
i do understand that there are many
other factors that play into account
like
the fact that i look so much younger so
i i always try and overcompensate for
that a little bit
but um yeah it might be the gender thing
as well but regardless of whether i
think it's normal whether it is
normal i do want to try and
help to make it so it's not normal
in the future and we shouldn't have to
guard ourselves as much as
some of us do already exhausted it
hasn't even started yet
okay let's just get into the
nitty-gritty and i'll talk to you about
the red flags that
could happen and what to do if they do
happen
so first i understand that it's really
hard to get your foot in the door of the
games industry and that's what you hear
all the time it can take years and it
can take a degree
and sometimes it can take a masters but
if you're
passionate and you work hard enough
there's no reason why
you should not be striving to
be a part of an industry and
do a job that that you love maybe love
is a bit cheesy that you feel
that you're right for and one of the
best pieces of advice that i've ever
been
given about finding a job and going into
a job interview
is to always remember that an interview
is not only for that company to see
whether
they would like you to work with them
but it's also for
you to know whether you would like to
work with that company
and i'd like you just to think about
that when i tell you these
red flags if you are in a business
meeting
or speaking to someone on business terms
in an interview
at an event whatever it is and you start
to
feel uneasy to see these red flags then
you do not have to impress this person
just because you haven't
gotten your foot in the door yet please
think about yourself
first for every person out there who
might make you feel uncomfortable
there will be other opportunities that
come up and
way way more people that would never
ever disrespect you in such a way of
course when you go in for interviews and
stuff i'm not saying that you should be
all
ballsy and oh do i want to work for you
but just keep in mind that uh the
company culture
the way they treat you the way that you
feel in their presence the way that they
talk about
the game that they're working on that's
already interesting
as well and you know you should be
asking yourself
can i see myself here do i want to work
with these people do they
excite me does the project excite me so
many different things i'm getting off on
a tangent now so i'll go back
okay i wrote a little list so i'll just
i'll just rattle off i know it can be
very very
difficult when you're just sending out
cvs and you're not hearing anything back
and you're getting very disheartened
you're thinking am i good enough and all
of these things it's very easy to get
swept away and excited by the promise
of a job opportunity within an industry
that you've been trying so hard
to break into but please don't get
excited
over a direct message talking to you
about a job opportunity
or an internship or anything like that
honestly from my experience
it's not professional to
talk about things like that or offer
opportunities like that through a direct
message
i could be talking complete bull but
don't get too excited about it don't
ignore them you know talk to them
they could be completely legit and
carrying on from that
if they have offered you an interview
and then they keep on messaging you
about your personal life
something that isn't work related don't
don't go
just do not go stop talking to that
person even if they are
a ceo of some games
company or something it's not
professional
if they wanted you for your skills and
your talent they wouldn't want to know
what you're having for dinner and
personally what to do in that situation
well if you are being uh
dm'd if you are being asked personal
questions
you don't have to shut it down
immediately i understand
that there's that hope that perhaps this
person
really does just want to give you a job
and that job is something you've been
waiting for
so just formally ask them to send you
an email that has the job description
and leave it leave it do not entertain
any small talk
just say thank you so much for the offer
i would love to hear more
please send me an email on my business
email
and i will get back to you yeah that's
still pleasant
it's still pleasant okay okay here's
another one
if you are in a business environment
whether that
be you've already gotten a job in the
games industry or perhaps
you're at a networking event or
something like that
and someone asks you whether you would
like to go for dinner or for drinks
this can be an awkward situation because
you might be
scared that it might be in a date
pretense
but you don't pretence yeah that is the
right word
but you don't want to give off the wrong
impression and you
also don't want to take it the wrong way
and then
look like a fool because this person was
actually just trying to
get to know you or even possibly open up
some more opportunities for you
so what do you do you reply saying
sounds great who else will be there
tinting
i think that's a good reply and i did
that once
and it does work if nobody else will be
there
then i would suggest asking
if you can take a friend along or take
someone else along with you
if other people will be there then you
know it's going to be
either a social thing or perhaps a
business thing
it's just going to be less awkward and
if they then realize that you're asking
this question because
you are feeling a bit on edge then
good on them they understand hopefully
they'll just be
be nice and open about it i mean
obviously all of this is up to you
okay here's another one if your
appearance gets brought up
in a business sense then skedaddle
run get out of there honestly the game
industry
does not care what you look like there
is no dress code
in the games industry one of the reasons
why i love it so much
so um if people are complimenting you in
a
very kind of flirtatious fashion
and it makes you feel uncomfortable you
know your own boundaries really think
about
what this person or this job is offering
you
and whether you feel comfortable with it
everyone likes to compliment every now
and then i'm not saying
you can't compliment people i
complimented my colleague on a scarf
once
he was very confused if it's in a
flirtatious manner
if it's um over the top especially if it
is
a job interview i know this is this is
very kind of fine line territory i'm
very sorry
you know the difference between someone
saying oh hi welcome
in oh i like your shirt it matches the
oh this has happened before someone came
up to me and said
oh i like your shirt it matches our
sofas
and it actually did i was wearing the
same striped shirts
as their sofas and that was amazing and
it broke the ice and it made the
interview go very smoothly but however
if you're
sat there and someone is asking you
questions about personal life romantic
life
um or there's saying you know oh you got
a beautiful smile
and that's never happened to me though
i'm just putting that out there that
would be a red flag but
that has never happened to me whew so
this is a really tricky one so perhaps
you've been
contacted through social media uh or
even your business email
uh or you've met someone at a
networking event gaming event something
like that
and um they've asked to meet you
for a coffee for an event for a possible
opportunity uh and they want you to
travel for that for a few hours or
something
it's tricky because you never really
know
if what they're offering is going to be
exactly the same as what you will
experience when you get there
but my advice to you would be
if you feel comfortable enough then
ask for your travel to be reimbursed i
feel like if you
feel comfortable enough to ask that and
then they um
respond in a respectful and
understanding manner
and especially if they're willing to
help pay towards that then they're
definitely
serious in what they are offering for
you
um and make sure to not go alone
i really hope that uh all people who
feel this way
are out of the education
sector now but if you get told
by someone who is supposed to
teach you um that the games industry is
for boys
and that you shouldn't be doing it
which i got told i didn't i didn't get
told i shouldn't be doing it but i got
told
why do you want to make games that's for
boys
use that to your advantage show them
what you can do show them what your
[ __ ] gender can do and ace that class
yes [ __ ] um
which is exactly what i did and whenever
you get told
by other people that
you are filling a gender gap
or just filling some sort of diversity
quota
remind yourself of this you have your
own personal reasons
why you're passionate about video games
and passionate about wanting to work in
the video game industry
don't let anybody take that away from
you
because of your gender do not question
why you feel compelled to be a part of
this
industry if you do you know
whether that is fake or not you were not
trying to appeal to another gender
i'm getting very emotional now it is not
easier for you because you are a girl
if anything it's difficult
because you have to come keep on
reminding yourself that you are worth
more
than your gender because you are you're
here because you're a girl
and you're this because you're a girl if
anyone judges you
based on your gender and your gender
alone then either ignore them and if you
can't
ignore them which is totally fine
because i've definitely been in that
situation then cut them off
do not let them into your life do not
let them speak these toxic words to you
especially if it's making you question
why you are pursuing
what you're pursuing why do you need to
justify yourself you can be feminine and
be
in the games industry you can wear
makeup
you can wear dresses you can
be girly and also
be real good at games
you can also maybe code and 3d model and
do sound design
and just game design in general you can
be
in the games industry and be a girl
and you shouldn't have to justify that
thank you so much for sticking to the
end because here is the real kicker here
a lot of the experiences that i have
experienced
actually weren't in the games industry
turns out it happens in a lot of a lot
of industries and some of my
worst experiences yeah they weren't in
the games industry they were before i
came to the games industry so please
do not be afraid and do not think that
you're not welcome here you are
since i have been working in the games
industry after leaving
university i've been around so many
supportive
and inclusive people and i'm really
happy to have had such a positive
experience
so far so i just want to share that part
with you as well
i want you to know it can be great
and that these uncomfortable
and disrespectful situations
can happen in other industries too
it's not just the game industries
however i understand
that in a more heavily male
dominated environment this could be
more the case but there's so
many people within this industry who
aren't like that
who will treat you with respect who do
want to help you
and who see you as a human
oh my being okay so
my card just ran out of space
and i ended up smashing some of my
um plant bars so that's great i will
share
some links down in the description below
of some females
in the games industry who i think are
really inspiring
and who i look up to and uh one off the
top of my head
is natalia from a company called
killmonday games she is a co-founder of
it
and she makes youtube videos and stuff
and they made
games like fran beau i look up to her i
think she's really really cool
and definitely an inspiration and there
are many other
females here um if you
have more questions about this if you're
going through something similar
then please uh give me a message
i will leave my email in the description
down below and i'll get back to you as
soon as i can i want to help i really
hope this came across okay because
at the end of the day i do not regret
all my decisions i don't regret
working my ass off to get into the games
industry
because it's what i'm passionate about
and it's what i find fun i'd love for
more people to
be able to say the same to finish this
video i just wanted to
share a little bit at the end that was
taken in a time when i was
less emotional let's just put it that
way i put out a tweet just to see how
many people think that the
games industry is intimidating and
whether they would try
and pursue a career in it and
interestingly um it got 88 votes
more than 50 said they're intimidated
i just want to read through some of the
comments that i had
maybe it can be a talking point down in
the comments below so a lot of the
comments that i'm getting are about
crunch times and lack of job security
which uh worries people i would just
like to say
that since i have found a job in the
industry i've never had to worry about
my job safety
maybe i'm just very lucky and i know
that it's definitely not the case in
all companies but just because it is a
gaming company
does not mean that you have to work
crazy over time
or that your job isn't secure that is
totally not the case
there are times and i think this is
inherent across
most creative industries that when you
come to a big deadline like releasing
your game or releasing a film
or something like that you probably will
have to work
harder and work overtime but you're not
forced to
or at least not in my experience i know
the stories i've heard the stories
but what you don't hear is the amount of
companies that don't force them
employees to do that
um you can if you want to but it's not
found upon if you can't
so as long as you get your work done
and you work your designated hours it's
all good a lot of it was about salary
and i guess yeah from from my experience
and from what other people have told me
you don't choose the game industry
because you want to be rich
you don't you choose the game industry
because you're passionate about it
and i i guess some of you also might be
worried about
how you would be perceived whether that
be through
gender or sexual orientation sexual
preference
i can understand that worry especially
in a primary primarily male
dominated environment you might think
that might be a certain way i mean very
lady and like
that's my loud impression but there's
way more than just males in the industry
there's way more than just heterosexuals
in the industry
as i said before treat the interview
um for yourself as well as for the
company to know whether you want to work
there
see how they are see how they interact
and see if you can envision yourself
working well with these people that's
that's all i can say to you
every company obviously has a culture
they do have a culture and uh that
culture is
a really important part of working with
people if you don't gel with them how
are you supposed to get creative with
them and have fun with them
on the front of some people just wanting
to create their own games and their own
thing that's completely understandable
and you know being an indie developer
and getting money another way
um to sustain you doing that totally
fine
if you want to make games you don't
necessarily have to work in a big games
company
that's absolutely a legit response
and there's a lot of people who are down
on themselves you guys
you're creative you're passionate
there's this
understanding that if you want to work
in the games industry you have to be
both like creative and clever and all
these things
being creative is not uh
i'd like to say it's not as hard as you
think it is but i mean that's
just my own opinion um
believe in yourself just believe in
yourself a little bit more
you don't have to be this god-like
really super intelligent person
you do have to work hard and be
motivated and passionate
yes and of course it really does help if
you do enjoy
games and you do like to pick them apart
and wonder what makes them work and
why people love to play in general but
yeah you don't have to be some super
genius
uh so there's that hope that helps just
answering some questions and
some things that that you might want to
hear because i know
primarily that video or this video sorry
was me talking to myself
and uh maybe it felt a bit too exclusive
but let's carry on the conversation down
in the comments below
have a lovely day or evening bye
[Music]
oh [ __ ]